foreign
over Guatemala's national election
a Guatemala City Barista says she's
trying to stay optimistic
whatever happens I feel that we should
take it in a positive way and extract
something good from it because there
will always be something negative
Galley start to Echo the minds of many
Guatemalans as the nation prepares to
cast its vote
the lead-up to the election between
center-left candidate Bernardo Arevalo
and former first lady Sandra Torres has
been marked by smear campaigns
allegations of Fraud and even concerns
over the Integrity of the democratic
process
the upcoming national election not only
represents a critical test of Guatemalan
democracy there's concerns over
worsening crime food security and
climate change but it's the question
over how to jumpstart the nation's
economy that resonates most among voters
one of the greatest challenges
Guatemala's next president will face is
creating prosperity in a deeply unequal
country where over 60 percent of the
population lives below the poverty line
poverty is compounded by unemployment
Wars and wage conditions and also the
increasing prices between 2021 and 2022.
the basic cost of living Rose by 12
percent but salaries only increased by
one so this reality is generating an
immediate and daily concern among
Guatemalans
economists say a lack of job
opportunities makes Guatemala one of the
countries with the highest immigration
rates in Latin America
eighty percent of the economically
active population is engaging in formal
labor therefore when population can find
formally employment they typically have
two options working in informal sector
or migrating to the United States
the owner of deco's coffee shop says
despite voter anxiety there is hope the
winner of Sunday's election will have
the necessary qualities to stir the
nation toward a brighter economic future
but there the people will have their say
what we are going to do is try to
continue working in the best way
fulfilling our obligations to the extent
we can because the situation is also
complex
much like the intricate art of Brewing
the perfect cup of coffee addressing the
many economic challenges facing the
country will require a delicate balance
of policy and strategy
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Guatemala City
foreign